PROFESSOR: So now we start
on a unit of about a half
a dozen lectures on probability
theory which most students have
been exposed to, to some
degree, in high school.
We'll be taking a more
thorough and theoretical look
at the subject in our six
lectures but, before we begin,
let's give a little pitch
for the significance of it.
There's been extensive
debate among the faculty
that probability theory belongs
right up there with physics
and chemistry and
math as something
that should be a fundamental
requirement for all students
to know.
It plays an absolutely
fundamental role
in the hard sciences,
and the social sciences,
and in engineering that
pervades all those subjects.
And it's hard to imagine
somebody legitimately being
called fully-educated if they
don't understand the basics
of probability theory.
Historically, probability
theory starts off
in a somewhat disreputable
way in the 17th and early 18th
centuries with the
analysis of gambling,
but then it goes on to be
the basis for the insurance
industry and underwriting,
predicting life expectancies,
so that you could understand
what kind of premiums
to charge.
And then it goes on to allow
the interpretation of noisy data
with errors in it and
the degree to which it
confirms scientific and
social science hypotheses.
But true to the
historical basis,
let's begin with an
example from gambling
that illustrates the
first idea of probability
and then we're going
to be working up
to a methodology for inventing
probability models, called
the tree model.
So let's begin with
an example from poker
and I'd like to ask a question.
If I deal a hand of
five cards in poker,
what's the probability of
getting exactly two jacks?
So there are 13 ranks
and there are four kinds
of jacks-- space,
hearts, diamonds,
clubs-- what's the probability
that, among my five cards,
I'm going to get two of them?
Well, that's really
a counting problem
because I'm going to
ask, first of all, how
many possible five-card
hands are there?
We can think of these as the
outcomes of a random experiment
of just picking five cards.
And there are 52 choose
5 five-card hands
in a 52-card deck.
Then, there are 4
choose 2 ways of picking
the suits for the two
jacks that we have
and so the total number of hands
that have two jacks is simply 4
choose 2 times 52 minus
4, the remaining 48 cards,
choose the remaining 3
cards in the five-card hand.
And then what we would say
is that the probability
of two jacks is
basically the number
of hands with two jacks divided
by the total number of hands.
Turns out to be about 0.04
and, under this interpretation,
basically, what we're
thinking of probability
as telling us is, what
fraction of the time
do I get what I want?
What's the fraction of the
time that I quote, "win" ,
if winning consists of getting
a pair of jacks and, by symmetry
and the fact that we think of
one hand is as likely to come
up as another, this fraction
of hands that equal two jacks,
it makes sense to think of that
as that's the probability that
we'll get that hand.
If we think of all the hands
as being equally likely,
we yank 1 out of the
deck, the fraction of time
that we would expect to get
two jacks is this number.
About 0.04.
So, the general
setup of probability,
the first idea based
on this illustration
with a pair of jacks,
is that, abstractly, we
have some random
experiment that's
capable of producing outcomes.
These are mathematical
black boxes called outcomes.
Now, a certain set
of the outcomes,
we will think of as an event
that we're interested in
whether or not it happens.
We could think of
it as the event
of getting two jacks or the
event of winning some game.
Then we define the
probability of an event
as simply the fraction
of the outcomes
in the event divided by the
total number of outcomes.
Among all the outcomes,
what fraction of outcomes
are in the event?
And we define that to be the
probability of the event.
That's the first naive idea
about probability theory
and it applies to a lot
of cases, but not always.
So now, let's begin
with an example which
illustrates why this first
idea needs to be refined
and it doesn't really
give us the kind of theory
of probability that we'd like.
So let's turn to a game that
was really famous in the 1970s.
An enormously popular
TV game hosted
by a man named Monty Hall.
The actual name of the TV show
was called Let's Make a Deal,
but we'll refer to it
as the Monty Hall game,
and the way that this
Let's Make A Deal show
worked was, roughly, that
there were three doors.
This is an actual
picture of the stage set.
Door 1, door 2, door 3.
And by the way, this game
show still has a fan base.
There's a website for
it that you can look at.
Even 40 years later,
people are still caught up
in the dynamics of the game.
So there are these
three doors and the idea
is that behind
the doors, they're
going to have a prize
behind one of them
and some kind of booby
prize, often a goat held
by a beautiful woman
holding a goat on a leash
just to keep things
visually interesting,
and that's what you
got if you lost.
And contestants were going
to somehow or other pick
a door and hope that
the prize was behind it.
There's a picture of the staff.
There's Monty Hall
and the woman who was
his assistant, Carol Merrill.
Her job was to pick doors
to open and show them
to contestants to see
what was behind them.
OK.
So here are the rules
for the Monty Hall game.
The actual quiz show
had more flexible rules
but, for simplicity, we're going
to define a simple, precise,
and fixed set of rules.
The rules are that, behind the
three doors, two of the doors
are going to have goats
and one of the doors
is going to have
a prize behind it.
Often the prize is something
like an automobile.
Something really desirable.
So we can assume that the
staff, on purpose, will
place the price at random
behind the three doors
because they don't
want anybody to have
a guess that some doors
are more likely than others
to have the prize and
they're not allowed to cheat.
That is, once
they've decided which
door is going to
have the price, it's
supposed to stay there
throughout the game.
They can't move it in
response to which door
that the contestants pick.
That would be cheating.
OK.
Next, the contestant
is given an opportunity
to pick one of the doors.
They're all closed and
it's hard to understand
how the contestant
would make a choice,
but if the contestant was
worried about the staff trying
to outguess him on
where to put the goat
and where to put the
prize, the contestant
should just pick all the
doors with equally likelihood.
Then he can't be beaten by
their trying to outguess him.
He can only be beaten
by if they cheated him
by moving the goat
after he picked
or moving the prize
after he picked.
At this point,
once the contestant
has picked a door-- let's
say he picks door 2--
then Monty instructs
Carol to open a door
with a goat behind it.
So he's going to choose
an unpicked door.
If the contestant
has picked door 2,
that means that door 1 and
door 3 are unpicked doors,
and Monty tells Carol,
open either door 1
or door 3, whichever
one-- or perhaps both--
have a goat behind them.
And so Carol is going to
open one of those doors
and show a goat
and everybody knows
that they're going to
see a goat because that's
the way the game works.
And then at this point,
when the contestant
has seen that there's a door
that has a goat behind it
and they're sitting
on a picked door
and there's another unopened
door that hasn't been picked,
the contestant's
job is to decide
whether to stick with the door
that they originally picked
or switch to the
other unopened door.
So if they picked door 2
and Carol opened door 3,
they could stick
with door 2 or they
could switch to
the closed door 1
and hope that maybe 1
has the price behind it.
Those are the rules of the game.
Now, the game got
a lot of prominence
in a magazine column written
by a woman named Marilyn Vos
Savant.
The name of the magazine
column was called Ask Marilyn
and she advertises herself as
having the highest recorded
IQ of all time, some
IQ of 200, and so she
runs a popular science
and math column
with various kinds of puzzles.
And she took up the analysis
of the Monty Hall statistics
and came to a conclusion
and the conclusion
caused a firestorm of response.
Letters from all
sorts of readers,
even quite sophisticated
PhD Mathematicians who
were arguing with her conclusion
about the way the game worked
and the probability
of winning according
to how the contested behaved.
The debate basically came
down to these two positions.
Position 1 said that
sticking and switching
were equally good.
It really didn't matter
what the contestant did,
whether they stuck with the
door that they originally
picked or switched
to the unpicked door
after the third
door had been opened
and that their likelihood of
finding the prize was the same.
And the other argument,
very emphatically,
said switching is much better.
You should really
switch no matter what.
And how can we
resolve this question?
Well, the general
method that we're
proposing for
dealing with problems
like this where we're
really trying to figure out,
what is the probability model?
Is to draw a tree that shows,
step-by-step, the progress
of the process or
experiment that's
going to yield a random output
and try to assign probabilities
to each of the
branches of the tree
as you go and use
that as a guide
for how to assign
probabilities to outcomes.
So let's begin, first
of all, by finding out
what the outcomes
are, and we're going
to be analyzing the
switch strategy.
So, just for definiteness,
let's suppose
that the contestant adopts the
strategy that they pick a door,
Carol opens a door
that shows a goat,
and they're going to switch
to the non-goat closed door
that they did not
originally pick.
They're going to switch
to the other door
that they can
switch to and we're
going to ask about,
what are the outcomes
and consequences of
winning or losing
if you adopt that strategy?
Well, the tree of
possibilities goes like this.
The first step in this
process that we've described
is that the staff picks
a prize location, a door
to put the prize behind, and so
there are three possibilities.
They could put the prize behind
door 1, door 2, and door 3.
OK Well, let's examine
the possibility that they
put the prize behind door 1.
So the next stage
is they pick a door
and if the prize is behind
one and they pick a door,
again, there are
three possible doors
that the contestant might pick.
The contestant has no
idea where the price is
and so the contestant can choose
either door 1 or door 2 or door
3.
At that point, the third
event in this random process,
or experiment, is that
Carol opens a door that
has a goat behind it.
So let's examine
those possibilities.
So, one possibility
is that the prize
is behind one and the contestant
picks door one, initially.
Well that means that Carol can
open either door 2 or door 3
in that circumstance
because both of them
have goats behind them.
On the other hand,
if the prize is at 1
and the contestant picks
door 2, the two closed doors
have-- one has the
prize, 1, and the other
doesn't have the prize, 3.
Carol has to open door three.
Likewise, if the
contestant picks
door 3 when the prize
is behind door 1,
Carol has to open door 2.
Here she's got a two-way branch.
She can choose to open either
of the two goat doors, 2 or 3.
Here there's only one
unopened door with a goat,
she's got to open 3 there, too.
OK.
And that describes the
outcomes of the experiment.
That's the process
of the experiment
and these nodes at the end,
these leaves of the tree,
describe the final
outcomes on this branch.
Now, if you look at
the classification
of these outcomes according
to winning and losing,
well, we're looking at
the switch strategy.
So if the price was behind 1
and the contestant picked door 1
initially, then their
strategy is to switch
and they're going to switch
away from the prize door.
So whichever door Carol opened
to reveal the goat, 2 or 3,
the contestant is going
to switch to the other one
and they're going to lose.
So both of these outcomes count
as losses for the contestant.
On the other hand, if the
prize was behind door 1
and the contestant
picked door 2,
then Carol opens the
non-prize door, 3,
and the contestant
switches from 2.
The only choice they have is
to switch to 1, the prize door.
They win.
And this other
case is symmetric.
And that summarizes
the wins and losses
in this branch of the tree.
Now, of course, the
rest of the tree
is symmetric so we don't need
to talk it through again.
This is just simply the case
where the prize is behind 2.
The contestant has
the same choices
and [? Marilyn ?]
has the same choices
of which unopened door
to choose and likewise
if the prize is behind 3.
So if we look at
this tree, the tree
is telling us that this
is an experiment which
we think of as having twelve
outcomes, four in each
of these major branches.
So there are twelve outcomes
of this random experiment,
of which, six are losses and
six are wins for the contestant
and so we discover that there's
six wins and six losses.
Now, the way that
this game works,
if you think about it-- if
the switching strategy wins,
that means that the
sticking strategy
would have lost because
if switching wins,
it meant that you switched to
the door that had the prize
and so if you
hadn't switched, you
must have been at a door
that didn't have the prize
and likewise.
If switching loses, then
you must have switched
from the door with the prize
to a door that didn't have
the prize-- switching-- and
that means if you'd stuck,
you would have won.
So what we can say is that
really analyzing the switch
strategy enables us
to analyze the stick
strategy simultaneously
because you win by sticking if
and only if you
lose by switching.
Now this simplification
doesn't hold
when there's more
than three doors,
and that's another
exercise, but for now, it's
telling us that if we
analyze the switch strategy,
we also understand
the stick strategy.
And of course, that means that
if you use the stick strategy
then the six wins become losses
and the six losses become wins
and, again, there are six ways
to lose and six ways to win.
So the first false
conclusion from this
is by reasoning about it as
though they were poker hands,
and the false
conclusion says, look,
sticking and switching win with
the same number of outcomes
and lose with the same
number of outcomes.
So it really doesn't
matter whether you stick
or switch because the
probability of winning,
in both cases, is
half the outcome.
6 out of 12.
The probability doesn't matter.
It makes no difference
whether you stick or switch.
And that's wrong, and
we will see why soon.
The other false
argument is that we
think about what happens
after Carol has opened a door.
So, where are we?
The contestant has picked
a door, has no idea
where the goat or the prize is.
Carol opens the door and
shows the contestant a goat.
What's left?
Well, there's two
closed doors left.
One is the door with
the prize and the other
is the door without the price
that has a goat behind it
and, by symmetry of the
doors, the contestant
has no idea what's behind
the door that he picked
or the remaining unopened door.
They're equally likely
to contain the prize
and so the argument is,
again, that whether you stick
or switch between those
two doors that haven't yet
been opened, it doesn't
really matter and so,
again, the stick strategy
and the switch strategy each
win with the same
50-50 probability.
And that's wrong, too.
What's wrong?
Well, let's go back and look
at this tree a little bit more
carefully to understand
what's going on.
And the first thing to
notice about the tree
is that the structure of the
tree leading to the leaves
is not the same.
Here's a leaf that
has degree [? 2. ?]
One way to get in
and only one way out
and here's a leaf
that has degree 3.
One way in and two ways out, if
we think of going from the root
to the leaf.
And so it's not clear that
these branches, these leaves,
should be treated the same way.
Well let's think about it more
carefully, about-- how are we
going to assign probabilities
to the various steps
of the experiment?
Well, what we're going to
assume, for simplicity,
is that the staff chooses a door
at random to place the prize.
So that means that
each of these branches
occurs with probability 1/3.
1/3 of the time, they put
the prize behind door 1, 1/3
behind door 2, and
1/3 behind door 3.
OK.
Let's continue exploring
the branch where they
put the prize behind door 1.
At that point, the contestant
is going to pick a door
and they can pick
either door 1, 2, or 3
and, absent any
knowledge and also
to be sure that they
can't be outguessed
by the staff realizing that
they mostly prefer door 1.
So if they're going
to switch, they'll
put the prize behind door
1 to fool the contestant.
The contestant's protection
is, pick a door at random.
Choose door 1 1/3 of the time,
and door 2 1/3 of the time,
and door 3 1/3 of the time in
a completely unpredictable way.
And so the contestants
is going to choose
each of those possible
doors as their first choice
with probability 1/3.
Now what happens next?
Well, the next
thing that happens
is that Carol opens a door.
Now this is the case
where Carol has a choice.
The prize is behind
one and the contestant
happened to pick door 1.
That means doors 2
and 3 both have goats
and, again, for
simplicity, let's
assume the Carol, when she
has a choice-- she can open
either door 2 or door
3, here-- does them
with equal probability.
So we're going to assign
probability 1/2 to her opening
door 2 when she has the
choice between 2 or 3
and probability 1/2 that she'll
open door 3 and, by the way,
we saw that those were losing
outcomes for the contestant.
But here, things are
a little different.
If the prize is behind
door 1 and the contestant
has chosen door 2,
Carol has no choice
but to open the
only other unchosen
door with the goat
behind, namely, door 3.
So we could say that
this choice, really,
is probability 1 and I got a
little bit ahead of myself here
but, having filled
in the probabilities
on these edges,
what we figured out
is that the probability of
this topmost branch of losing
is we said, well, 1/3
of the time you go here
and 1/3 of that third you
go here and 1/2 of that time
you go to this vertex.
So it's 1/3 of 1/3 and 1/2
of that, or a weight of 1/18
and, by symmetry,
this gets weight 1/18.
But this way, 1/3 of the time,
the prize is behind door 1.
1/3 of the time, the contestant
picks door 2 and after that,
Carol is was forced
to open door 3.
So this branch occurs
with certainty, as
with probability 1, which
means that we wind up
at this leaf 1/3 of 1/3
of the time for sure,
and its weight is 1/9.
And of course, by symmetry,
the similar weights
get assigned to the
winning and the losing.
So what we've concluded is that,
although there are six wins,
the weight of the wins
is 6/9 because they're
each worth 1/9 of the
time and that winning
will occur 2/3 of the time.
Likewise, there are six
losses but they each
only occur 1/18 of the time
and so we lose 1/3 third
of the time by the
switch strategy.
The summary, then, is
that the probability
of winning if you switch
is 2/3 and, by the remark
that you win with
switching if and only
if you lose with sticking,
it follows that you lose
by sticking 2/3 of the time.
And so sticking is really a
bad strategy and switching
is the dominant way to go.
Now, in class, we back up
this theoretical analysis.
It's very logical but the
question is, is it true?
And you can do
statistical experiments
and have students pick
doors and goats and prizes
and, sure enough, it turns out
that roughly 2/3 of the time,
and closer and closer to 2/3 the
more times you play the game,
the switching strategy
wins 2/3 of the time.
So, the second key idea
in probability theory
is that the outcomes may
have different probabilities.
They may have different weights.
Unlike the poker hand case,
when we look more closely
at a random experiment
with different outcomes,
we will agree that, for various
kinds of reasons of symmetry
or logic and so on,
that it make sense
to assign different
probability weights
to the different outcomes.
It's not the case
that the outcomes
have uniform probability, that
they're all equally likely.
So, to summarize, what happens,
especially-- this example
illustrates the confusion
about of probability theory
that was engendered to
even some serious experts--
but, in general, intuition
is very important,
as in any subject, but it's
also dangerous in probability
theory.
Particularly, for beginners who
aren't experienced about some
of these traps that
you can fall into
and so our proposal
is that you be very
wary of intuitive arguments.
They're valuable but you
need another disciplined way
to check them, and
we propose that you
stick with what we call the
four-part method when you're
trying to devise a
probability model
for some random experiment.
So, the steps are,
first, that you
try to identify the outcomes
of the random experiment
and this is where the
tree structure comes up.
If you try to
model, step-by-step
at each stage of the tree,
what the possible sub-steps are
in the overall process that
yields the random outcome,
that's where the
tree comes in as we
illustrated with Monty Hall.
The next thing to do
is, among the outcomes,
identify the ones
that you consider
to be of the winning events
or the winning outcomes
or the outcomes in the event
that you are concerned about
whether or not it happens.
Getting two jacks, picking
the door with the prize.
So you need to identify the
target event whose probability
you're interested in.
We could call it the winning
event, the probability
of winning.
The third key step is to try
to use the tree and logic of it
to assign probabilities
to the outcomes
and the fourth step,
then, is, simply,
to compute the probability
of the event which
you do in a very
straightforward way
by basically adding up
the probabilities of each
of the outcomes in the event.
That is the four-step method.
Now, this Monty Hall
tree that we came up with
was very literal and wildly,
unnecessarily complicated.
So let's take another look at
that and a simpler argument
that will lead us to the
same conclusion about how
the Monty Hall game
works, and we'll
do that in the next video.